cette vidéo est sponsorisé par la maif
et leur site mais data et moi plus
d'informations en fin de vidéo combien
de temps ça va durer c'est une question
que je me pose très souvent combien de
temps j'ai avant de devoir arroser mes
plantes combien de temps j'ai avant de
devoir sortir du métro combien tanger
avant la date de péremption de ses
yaourts pour le manger combien de temps
je pourrai faire de vidéos avant que
l'internet ne s'intéresse à quelqu'un
d'autre combien de temps j'ai avant de
pouvoir faire des enfants combien de
temps va encore durer cette relation
cette amitié cet amour et surtout
combien tanger avant de mourir cette
question de la temporalité elle est
omniprésent dans tout ce que je fais
elle est la conséquence d'une vérité
fondamentale une des trois marques de
l'existence dans le bouddhisme
anice
l'impermanence tout est impermanent
demain monstre havas regatta jusqu'à une
ampoule qui un jour ou l'autre grira
enfin c'est ce que je pensais c'est ce
que je pensais avant de tomber sur la
caserne des pompiers de livermore en
californie
voici un livestream dans la caserne et
voici une ampoule ce n'est pas une
simple ampoule cette ampoule est dans le
guinness book des records elle brille
depuis 1901 quasiment sans interruption
elle brille depuis plus d'un million
d'heures tellement fou que quand elle a
passé ce million d'heures des gens lui
ont souhaité un joyeux anniversaire
[Musique]
et
à
hahaha
comment c'est possible est ce qu'il ya
des gens qui sont capables de faire des
ampoules qui vont durer des millions
d'heures et d'autres qui en sont
simplement incapable ce serait bizarre
et un temps l'autre option c'est à dire
qu'on sache faire des ampoules qui est
dur des millions d'heures mais qu'on
décide de ne pas le faire
je trouve ça bizarre aussi quoi jusqu'à
ce que je batte ce documentaire ce film
révèle comment l'obsolescence programmée
détermine nos vies depuis les années 20
lorsque les fabricants commencèrent à
raccourcir la durée de vie des produits
pour accroître la demande des
consommateurs on apprend que dans les
années 20 il ya un cartel de fabricants
dans pool qui a décidé de sciemment
limiter la durée de vie des ampoules à
miller c'est pas quelqu'un on n'a pas
limité à 1000 heures genre c'est un mec
et on vendrait que des ampoules a mis
leur nom c'est 1000 heures voilà miller
donc ça brille que miller et après c'est
fini et ce délire immense porte un nom
ça s'appelle l'obsolescence programmée
et pour en apprendre un peu plus je vais
sur le site mais tata et moi de l'amf
partenaire de cette vidéo et gilly les
choses suivantes l'obsolescence
programmée à plusieurs visages la
définition officielle est la suivante
l'obsolescence programmée se définit par
l'ensemble des techniques par lesquels
un metteur sur le marché vise à réduire
délibérément la durée de vie d'un
produit pour en augmenter le taux de
remplacement autrement dit c'est la
réduction volontaire de la durabilité
d'un produit afin d'en vendre plus
souvent wahou alors on met de côté un
instant les questions philosophiques du
début de la vidéo la de combien de temps
ça dure et c'est pour parler économie
donc en gros l'obsolescence programmée
elle a émergé en même temps que la
production de série et la société de
consommation les machines elles ont
accéléré la production mais les
consommateurs ils n'arrivent pas à
suivre du coup il ya eu un excès de
production si on répond à tous les
besoins du consommateur ils n'achètent
plus s'ils n'achètent plus les
entreprises ne vendent pas ces
entreprises ne vendent pas elle coule
donc on a sciemment limiter la durée de
vie de nos produits enfin
c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça on
lisait juste avant dans mes data et moi
qu'il ya plusieurs manières de générer
cet effet d'abord l'obsolescence
technique ou fonctionnel en gros au bout
d'un moment l'objet cesse de fonctionner
et soit c'est pas du tout réparable très
difficilement ou alors c'est juste pas
rentable en fait de le réparer pour
l'anecdote c'est une obsolescence qui
avait dénoncé caitlin istat bien avant
d'être celui qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
sur youtube puisque c'était d'ailleurs
trois ans avant que youtube existe il
avait fait une vidéo sur l'ipod il aller
taguer sur toutes les pubs ipod à new
york ipod un triplex vos batteries last
song est étonnante ce que veut dire la
batterie non remplaçable de l'ipod ne
dure que 18 mois c'est une obsolescence
assez proche du nôtre obsolescence qui
est l'obsolescence logiciels en gros
avec la mise à jour de certains
logiciels et le manque de mise à jour
d'autres logiciels il ya parfois des
dysfonctionnements et des
incompatibilités donc parfois vous êtes
obligés d'acheter une version plus
récente en revanche et une dernière
obsolescence qui est beaucoup plus
subtile c'est l'obsolescence esthétique
en fait sans changer une quelconque
fonctionnalités ou un élément technique
dans le produit on va le rendre obsolète
simplement en sortant un autre produit
qui est censé être mieux ou tendance
c'est une obsolescence qui frappe
beaucoup par exemple l'industrie de la
mode quand vous achetez une veste à
votre veste elle tient est généralement
avant de changer de veste bas votre
veste et tient toujours quoi si vous le
changez c'est pas parce que
techniquement ça marche plus non c'est
juste la mode qui changeait en fait
votre veste elle devient obsolète alors
qu'elle fait toujours le taf c'est donc
une obsolescence qui se fait du côté du
fabricant parce que bas il va nous
donner envie d'acheter ces nouveaux
produits mais ça c'est aussi de notre
côté parce qu'en fait on pourrait aussi
se contenter de ce qu'on a mais on veut
toujours plus le truc c'est que cette
obsolescence programmée elle est
tellement présente est tellement
imbriquée dans notre modèle de société
que c'est difficile de voir comment
pourrait faire sens parce que
effectivement ainsi plus personne
n'achète dans pool bas les gens qui font
les ampoules ils sont au chômage en fait
mais le truc c'est que cette
obsolescence et pose un réel souci est
le souci vous avez deviné il et
environnemental on vit dans un monde
avec de ressources finies donc on peut
pas produire à l'infini c'est pas
durable sur si tu mets data et moi on
apprend par exemple qu'un téléphone
portable nécessite 70 matériaux
différents et 90 % de l'empreinte
écologique d'un appareil est émise lors
de sa fabrication on sait à quel point
le recyclage est difficile pour certains
produits il suffit de regarder la
décharge d'akbou blanchi au ghana pour
s'en rendre compte certains pays se font
submergé par nos déchets et n'ont pas
les moyens de les traiter sachant que la
plupart du temps ces mêmes parents
cyclables sur les milliers d'ordinateurs
récupérer y aura seulement 10 ou 20%
qu'ils trouvent un second souffle alors
conçu reproduit on devrait plutôt
réfléchir à ne produire que ce dont on a
besoin un truc un peu plus en accord
avec la nature et puis j'ai regardé les
feuilles mortes sur mon balcon
ce que je devais les ramasser parce que
y'a plein de feuilles mortes ou même je
regardais mes plantes en fait je me suis
dit la nature elle n'arrête pas de
produire en fait elle sur produit même
lorsqu'un arbre fait des fruits il fait
ses fruits que quelqu'un démange ou non
aucun animal les mange ou non quelqu'un
humains l'écueil ou pas il fait ses
fruits en fait et si personne ne les
prend et bien il va sur produire et les
fruits vont tomber et vont pourrir la
seule différence c'est que tout ce
qu'elle produit se dégrade naturellement
en elle elle aussi en fait comme on
disait au début elles comportent
intrinsèquement
cette obsolescence et cette impermanence
rien et durable et tout ne fait que se
dégrader à et des initiatives qui vont
dans le sens de la nature par exemple
cette marque de textile il n'ajoute
aucun composant chimique à leurs tissus
de sorte à ce que les tissus soit hyper
peu dégradables et reviennent
extrêmement facilement à la terre
peut-être qu'en acceptant l'obsolescence
qui nous touche le plus c'est à dire la
nôtre on serait capable de s'éloigner de
l'obsolescence programmée de ce qu'on
consomme 6 g pleine conscience de ma
mortalité et du fait que je suis que de
passage
quelle est l'importance d'avoir le
dernier appareil dernier cri en fait si
les humains acceptent leur caractère
éphémère est ce qu'ils seront toujours
appâtés par la recherche du gain qui
nous pousse à surproduire avec la crise
sanitaire on a vu de nombreux produits
être en pénurie ça peut être des
smartphones des consoles de jeux des
cartes graphiques mais ça peut être
aussi ma des véhicules des médicaments
des jouets
des composants électroniques et même du
papier dans un article de tv5 monde il
ya laurent ferrara un professeur
d'économie internationale qui disait la
chose suivante avec l'énergie trop cher
les capacités de production des
industriels sont donc largement en
dessous de leur potentiel c'est un
phénomène est lié aux prix puisque avec
des coûts des matières premières et du
frais trop élevés pour ne pas perdre
trop de marge les industriels produisent
en moins grande quantité actuellement en
france il ya des délais de neuf mois à
un an si vous voulez acheter une voiture
neuve donc en fait ce qui se passe en ce
moment avec certains produits nous
pousse à consommer différemment et d'une
certaine manière ça nous pousse à
consommer d'une façon qui n'est plus en
adéquation avec l'obsolescence
programmée alors c'est sûrement
temporaire mais c'est intéressant de se
projeter dans un monde où lorsqu'on veut
nouvelle voiture faux potentiellement
attendre neuf mois parce qu'on en
produit moins et s'il faut attendre neuf
mois aux nouvelles voitures on va
peut-être faire en sorte qu'elle dure
plus longtemps enfin j'espère la bonne
nouvelle c'est que cette notion
d'obsolescence programmée elle est de
plus en plus connu par le grand public
ce qui fait qu'il ya même des lois sur
le site mais data et moi on nous dit par
exemple qu'en france depuis 2015
l'obsolescence programmée est considérée
comme une pratique trompeuse est illégal
et il ya des lois en comme la loi du 17
août 2015 relatives à la transition
énergétique pour la croissance verte ou
la loi du 10 février 2000 20 qui définit
les sanctions relatives à la lutte
contre le gaspillage et à l'économie
circulaire ce que nous on peut faire en
tant que citoyen c'est évidemment
réfléchir à deux fois avant d'acheter
quelque chose mais aussi avoir plus le
réflexe de réparer les choses c'est
quelque chose qu'on fait assez peu
et je vous avoue que moi j'essaie de le
faire de plus en plus et même quand je
répare un tout petit truc je vous sens
hyper jouissif quoi je pense que je fais
une vidéo sur le sujet en sueur sur
réparer des trucs
je trouve ça intéressant j'ai envie de
vous en parler on va réparer des trucs
ensemble car on n'a pas répondu à
combien de temps dure notre vie ça c'est
une question intéressante on aura
peut-être l'occasion de notre foi par
contre on a répondu à la question
combien de temps dure cette vidéo et le
résultat s'affiche easy way ya parfois
des réponses qu'on n'a pas tout de suite
mais on peut d'ores et déjà leur faire
de la place pour le moment où elles
arriveront merci au site mais data et
moi de la maif n'hésitez pas à aller
dessus pour voir la multitude d'articles
qu'ils proposent c'est à chaque fois des
articles assez court et concis sur des
thématiques très précises je trouve très
bien fait et j'ai appris plein de choses
par exemple est ce que vous saviez que
90% des français et françaises affirment
ne plus faire confiance aux influenceurs
et influenceurs vous avez pas ça ou que
64% des 16-18 ans n'utilisent pas
facebook je pensais pas que c'était au
temps où on verrait il ya plein de
ressources vous mets le lien juste en
dessous et je le remercie encore une
fois d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo
merci à vous d'avoir regardé jusqu'au
bout love peace je vous embrasse